on and on hey what is up guys I'm kabhi
HP here and I was just checking the
other day and it turns out I haven't
done one of these in nearly a year it
was February of last year so welcome to
the sort of annually expected what's on
my phone video you know sikozu free to
play fair warning to those of you who
saw last year's video a lot of the apps
are going to look very similar to that
I'm a lot of the set up is also going to
look very similar
mostly because I just kind of find what
I like and I go all in with it I keep it
pretty clean I don't keep that many
extra apps the pixel XL is a primary
phone and there's actually an iPhone 7
plus with a different SIM card in it as
my secondary phone but on main SIM and
the phone number that most people have
is the one that's currently in the pixel
XL on AT&T and if you can see pretty
close to stock it has the Google
launcher on it and basically I found
that still the more Google builds and
features into their stock apps and their
stock launcher the less I have to add
stuff with third-party apps so I'll you
can see last year I had a widget up at
the top for the weather and the
temperature this year it's built into
the Google launcher in Android 7.0 so
that's perfect it just clicks right into
the weather forecast so first of all
from my home screen you can swipe over
to the Google now cards which pretty
consistently gives me things like
weather NBA standings shipping
notifications and news mostly about tech
and which Clippers are the most recently
injured and this whole thing is pretty
useful but obviously an Android 7.0
there's the assistant and actually use
the assistant more than the Google now
cards but either way they're both nice
to have and then you have the main home
screen where I have all the most
frequently used and most frequently
opened apps so you have google photos
obviously that's where it keeps all the
photos from the camera and I'll
screenshots and everything you have
Google Maps and actually like these most
for the really useful desktop shortcuts
just two straight navigate home or
navigate to work really useful
yeah SoundCloud and Spotify I use both
these from music but I use Spotify
easily the most often out of any of them
and Instagram that's pretty obvious
YouTube studio still to monitor the
comments and things like that and then
the Tesla app which I did a whole video
about already so if you want to know
exactly what that app does you can check
out the video but it has a lot of
controls of the car inside and then
Google keeps and Google Tasks for my own
sanity that's my organizational apps and
to-do lists and MyFitnessPal again so
the same stuff
last year mostly to just count Nutrition
Facts and keep track of that but down at
the bottom of the dock I guess you'd say
is again the most important app so it's
the phone the messenger
it's Gmail for me and then Phoenix which
in my opinion is still the best Twitter
client for Android I still use the stock
Twitter app for notifications but for
everything else I use Phoenix and I also
still keep a camera shortcut in my dock
even though you still have the DoubleTap
of the power button to get into the
camera I find that sometimes when I'm
just on my home screen I want to go to
the camera I'll just use that app for
that I know I don't need the shortcut
but hey it's there now moving over to
the second screen I again have a nearly
full screen today calendar widget I'm
gonna try to link the major apps I
talked about in the description but this
is one of my favorites because it just
has a scrolling list of all the stuff in
my Google Calendar I can click in to
visit any of the events and add stuff
and it's sort of transparent I can
control all this so it works with pretty
much any wallpaper and then at the
bottom in my apps I have Dropbox pretty
similar YouTube uber and Google drives
and the Google Play Store and again all
these google apps since it's android 7.0
they now have these long press shortcuts
on the home screen i don't really use
these as much as i do for google maps
but again this is stuff that i expect to
see in more third-party apps in a little
bit so then moving over to the third
screen last but not least it might
actually be my most interesting
homescreen it's just a little collection
of apps that I use on a semi daily basis
so dark sky is a weather app that
actually started on iOS but is now on
Android it's really good actually shows
you some minute-by-minute forecast stuff
a really good map so dark skies worth
checking out I have a syllabus cue app
which I have Philips hue bulbs all over
the studio now so it helps to just be
able to turn these on and off and mess
with the color and it actually works
with Google home which just lets me
literally talk to the bulb to tell to
change colors really useful stuff so the
Yahoo fantasy sports app not killing it
quite as much as I was last year in the
basketball league but it's still there I
also have the nest app here and this is
new for me I have a couple of nest
products now too the thermostats and the
cameras so this is the app you use to
kind of monitor and control all of them
but yeah that's the apps that I have on
the couple of home screens everything
else like inside the app drawer is my
somewhat less used apps you might see a
couple in here that you recognize before
you fly ass as a brand
you want to have but pretty useful for
knowing if you're good or bad to go
ahead and fly a drone based on what's
near you I solve them my sound app for
my j-bird x3s
I still have screener for the beautiful
screenshots you've seen still up
periscope
but yeah overall you can see it's pretty
clean I keep a lot of the apps the same
over a long period of time because I get
to know them really well and they work
for what I do and that is the way my
homescreen set up so either way that's
been it thank you for watching hopefully
this gives you a better idea of the
setup and what's good with it
and I guess we'll look forward to the
same thing in another year so either way
thought to you guys the next one Hey
[Music]